what's happening there reject nation
greg and john here today to watch the
next episode of gravity falls now that
we have met bill cipher this is a
continuation of that episode hey full
length watch long as we sync with the
time crew for ge falls over at our
patreon page special thanks to all have
become super sexy rejects by checking
out all we got to offer over there and
if you can't follow us on patreon leave
a like that would help us out in the
algorithm a lot leave a comment
subscribe and click that notification
bell to get notified when our reaction
from the next gravity falls is up almost
done with this first season lastly
thanks to them super sexy prepper boys
super sexy print boys today for helping
us edit down these highlights let's get
to it
i just had a horrible dream that gideon
stole the deed to the mystery shack and
kicked us out and we all had to move in
with seuss's grandma that was no dream
dude
no grandma seuss this is all my fault
don't worry dipper looks like mabel's
gonna have to be the hero of the family
now i'll defeat gideon with my grappling
hook no offense but that grappling hook
has literally never helped us once oh
yeah jelly crab
[Music]
she looks like two-face
hey she does she gotta get the shack
back
in the shack back with the with the
gideon attack yeah attack put him up on
the ground back and crack some whack
with the well
get a snack at the at the shack
with playing ball with shaq
and snap back with the backpack at the
crack track attack tic-tacs with the
breath
and overhangs like it's field and
tractor collar black
smash that gideon
like need to fill in
with
with one million
we got it bars don't know what we're
doing here but i am loving these fake
mustaches neighborhood watch today i am
delighted to announce my new plans for
the former mystery shack i give you
gideon land
wow
i'm introducing our new mascot lil giddy
junior boom
no no mr pines i recall you gave the
property to me
look here's a deed right here well
that's all the proof i need to see i
love you lil gideon sing them funny
songs
what a bunch of [ __ ] don't worry
guys we'll get the shaq back somehow we
better wendy
if i can't work at the shack my dad's
gonna force me to work upstate at my
cousin's logging camp no
no don't leave especially dipper because
of his giant crush on
you
oh and what's stan gonna tell mom and
dad they're not dead i forgot what
happened to them i thought i couldn't
take care of these kids i'd send them
back right away
uh-huh you too
can we order pizza
[Music]
no
it's daniel
this is why money's the root of
happiness that's right
back to your corner
you not tree waddles that way tyrant
shouldn't you be celebrating gideon land
instead of sticking your head in that
their book all day father have i ever
told you the true nature of this book oh
my he hid his journals where he thought
no one would ever find him because he
knew that if the journals were ever
brought together they would unleash a
gateway to unimaginable power six
fingered hand so that's why you wanted
the mystery shack that's right father
it's time to begin the search for the
other journal
uh
how little does he know i don't have a
house or a job the plan is
you're going home your bus leaves
tomorrow here are your tickets but
grunkle stan you can't give up yeah dude
look at these faces be cuter mabel your
summer depends on it
best thing is for you to be with your
parents i'm sorry kids gideon won
summer's over mr pines come back
reconsider it's not how summer works if
stan won't get our home back from gideon
then we'll have to do it ourselves
gideon may have the upper hand but we
have one thing he doesn't
the journal
[Laughter]
us to take us out of gravity falls comes
at sundown if we want to stay in town
we've got to get past those guards make
it through the fence and get gideon to
hand over that deed
leave that to mabel what y'all
grappling hook butternut squash with a
human face and emotions yeah nope
whoa what's this i've stared at this
page for hours it seems like a blueprint
to build some kind of strange futuristic
super weapon
[Music]
wait a minute an army of darkness nose
going back to the beginning where it all
started this is normal this is normal
for gnomes scrub scrub
golly we need your help you want our
help after you left me at the altar no
dice well what if we were able to get
you a new queen what even more beautiful
than me her name's gideon and she has
lovely white hair whoa mature woman huh
oh my zeus what are you doing here since
the mystery shack shut down i've had to
take a bunch of part-time jobs
gravedigger bus driver really awesome
cook hey is the kitchen supposed to have
that much fire in it
[Laughter]
classic scream sound effect give us the
deed to the shack gideon or else
[Music]
barf on him
wow
[Music]
you're surrounded by an unstoppable
gnome army now give us back our deed and
get off our property an army i suppose
this deed belongs to
what do you know works on gnomes too
stop we'll do anything how can we serve
you your majesty
no give it back every victory you had
was because of your precious book give
it back or i'll or what boy you what huh
huh no muscle
god nothing without this
bye bye forever y'all
fear nothing without the book you don't
deserve to have it gideon was right the
only courageous or cool things i've ever
done have been because of that journal
without it i can't help you or stan
or anyone there's got to be something we
can do
what can we do pour your body out to the
squirrels
absolutely plus 52 departing gravity
falls all aboard
sorry kids it's for the best
oh so they were just there for the
summer
yeah i thought they died
yeah
i thought we would never see them again
journal number
three
there are three of them
that's what i was thinking earlier i
must have all three for the power to be
unlocked but where can i
differ he must know where it is he gave
me the third one and kept the first for
himself i can't let him leave gravity
falls
oh my god
only one way to find out oh my god it's
a mecca gideon yes the thing of
nightmares
no
no
well stan this is it rock bottom no
friends no family stuck watching
infomercials for whatever that is are
you sick of piles of owls constantly
[Laughter]
thank you justin roiland maybe he really
is psychic after ah my hearing aid what
keeps causing that
wait a minute that's it i know gideon's
weakness with mr pines like it
oh miscellaneous fluid stain giant robot
yeah giant robot wait what look
oh
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
no
it's like a messed up iron giant
[Applause]
okay what's closest to our present
situation raccooning the engine or angry
grandparent won't leave bus
probably probably the second one
[Laughter]
how did it not break the bridge
i don't know what you're talking about
you took the only journal i ever had
i'll rule this town with you as my queen
liver dipper
save yourself
yeah he's not going through it
oh wow
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
stop hitting yourself
grab a tron
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
this is
quite a high-stakes episode damn
it's been intense
then i grabbed my
raffle
i didn't even think about that finally
completely forgot you got me show
they tried to attack me and blew up my
statue with dynamite arrest him
what officers he's lying
sorry kids but we trust gideon and
nothing short of a miracle could ever
change out
[Laughter]
oh i could never tell a lie i'm gideon
he's more honest than you yeah and he's
psychic too how's this for psychic bam
take a good look
wait a minute is that me whoa these pins
are hidden cameras and my hearing aid
was picking up the feedback
who's the fraud now
we gave you our trust you
kill him
evil dies tonight
you are under arrest for conspiracy
fraud and breaking our hearts
darling the tiny handcuffs
no
just one more thing
oh yeah i believe this belongs to me
no no not the hair you can't do this to
me y'all are sheep you need me
local hero stanford pines has just
exposed little gideon as a fraud
anything you have to say to the town
stanford the mystery shack is back baby
little giddy and evil minion
[Music]
dude this was great for business this is
a journal i found in the woods it talks
about all the crazy stuff that goes on
in gravity falls gideon nearly destroyed
the whole town trying to find it i don't
know what it means or who wrote it but
after all we've been through
maybe you should finally know about it
he's got the first book
spookums and monsters this kooky book
has been filling your head with crazy
conspiracy yeah yeah
you got to quit reading this fantasy
nonsense for your own good although some
of these would make great attractions
can't come up with this stuff what would
a boring old man like stan want with
that book anyway
[Music]
[Laughter]
looks like everything's back to normal
[Music]
oh my god we're finally doing this
we're doing this oh here we go
[Music]
the city may not know it yet but these
books are going to do a lot of good i've
got a photo of them
yeah for all these years
oh
we have them all
oh
no
[Music]
when you're finished type in your name
[Music]
here we go
what
i don't believe this was that the season
one finale
that was the finale it was the final
damn yeah and now we have to watch a
bunch of shorts
dude that was crazy that was insane
there were some dramatic heft this was a
hefty epi heft episode
my favorite trash bag brand
hefty
hefty episode hefty hefty hefty in this
episode
they took the trash out oh yeah
the trash be gideon in case you guys
didn't catch that
making some cash taking out the trash
[Music]
got the looks
gideon's a friggin crook
well i thought we're gonna do grappling
hook on that one grappling
[Music]
like he's gonna miss this opportunity
for something good for for putting that
out into the air and uh then you did it
you went dude what you did exactly the
same
difficult you know no it's not i know
you're you're right have you ever tried
rap battling easy peasy squeezy easy
sorry i i lied there
wow the
first gravity falls episode to really
really show like this took a different
tone
this was like a different direction for
the show
we started filling that up with the last
one it's weird that the show evolved
into like
wacky
wacky sci-fi supernatural adventures
monster of the week with some
something like you know consistent
serial storytelling and the last few
have been like way more ensemble
not much wendy but
we're ensembled and then the last two
especially have gotten like really
really focused up and we hadn't really
like let their their mystery theme and
tone
prevail a lot more
than just the the hijinx and uh
surprise you get like mecca gideon and
then get all like
iron giant at the end
absolutely get like dower that was crazy
that was crazy stuff still kept it
inventive and this is the first episode
where i was like damn just kidding it's
a threat mm-hmm yeah
all these kidding appearances
yeah yeah like for as maniacal as he
often presents himself like this was one
where i'm like yeah this is a scary
presence here he could destroy the whole
place
the wrong move
and uh yeah and he's like so he's is the
perfect villain because he's so
conniving and you just want to smack him
every step of the way and the way it
manipulated the townsfolk all the really
smart towns folks from gravity
who really take time to think and
consider things really funny characters
smart characters
i still know how i feel about them cops
they don't do their job much they they
are in the pocket of whoever's the most
charming
it's not good police work i know but
they don't it's always like the same
joke with them but they don't ever
really make me laugh
i find them amusing
in a presence kind of way but yeah i
mean it's pretty much they're in love
and they're incompetent in the most
specific to this situation way possible
what is that way this week
uh but no this was a really great
episode especially those like final
moments started turning into like an
amblin movie yeah man and like i love
that that it makes it feel like an
actual summer that you've spent where
it's like you have you know yeah the the
first chunk is just sort of you know
different sort of disparate little
adventures and then by the end it's like
okay you know like it evolves into
something more involved and it involves
into something that you can kind of
track and has
i don't know like a greater it's almost
like yeah going i would have to imagine
like going away you know for a whole
summer to a camp or something like that
you know it's like the first smattering
of days has to feel like just a bunch of
days and then by the time you reach sort
of a momentum there's a story there
and uh you know like that's quite the
place we've gotten to now you know i
forgot
oh did they ever establish the parents i
don't remember this i don't remember
ever seeing them i i mean i can i don't
remember even why they were i just
assumed they were dead so he was taking
care of them guardian i i they they
probably said something in the first
episode addressing it and yeah it's like
i'd forgotten to the point where until
they reminded us i was like
yeah they could easily be dead i thought
they might be dead yeah maybe that's a
little grim to start a show on but this
is for semi-older-ish kids anyway so you
know like they're not it doesn't seem
like they're afraid necessarily to at
least broach the idea that that could be
the case but yeah i guess they're fine
and uh they got a little blood in this
one yeah
which all you need is that one drop but
it is striking in this environment it
really is their animation's been very
expressive lately mm-hmm
like that that's kind of like a painting
the first uh
when gideon's mecca suit was like in the
ground the first time you see that that
and the big wide shot of them falling
into the valley and everything like yeah
there's some really beautiful
paint like things that look like
paintings and that look like those
uh you know like really beautiful you
can tell you can feel the tangibility of
like an older cartoon track drop where
you're like man
the background is like a fine art
painting yeah it's funny how often they
brought up the grappling hook and i
completely forgot about it on the moment
the moment they needed me to forget
about it yeah as well as well uh
misdirected there
and i actually like the use of the
fighting of how like
it might be too violent to see like
gideon
and uh dipper actually punching each
other a bunch yeah but the way they cut
to the suit a lot taking the hits and
punching and stuff but you can still get
the sound effects like there's something
kind of clever about masking your
violence with this oh yeah cause it's
still eerie to watch this big machine
going haywire and punch itself and yeah
and flail around
and and you know i feel like too you can
do things
that if you were doing them with real
human anatomy would be like bone
crunching and icky and and you know good
adult
i bet there's uh
amblin love here uh imbued in the show
because there's a sense of discovery i
would say in a lot of this yeah and
coming of age they even did the dinosaur
things recently and they like straight
up this is a t-rex chase on the bus yeah
absolutely
and i mean you know even even didn't uh
dreamworks made the iron giant which is
you know spielberg's involved in that
company too so there's amblin dna there
that's true i really liked uh i really
liked that they even they even allowed
dipper to have a good arc of feeling
like he's good enough and not being they
even think about that of how like
reliant he is on the book and learning
to be self-reliant solely and not be
reliant on the book
but it takes this show in a whole new
direction especially that's pretty crazy
that they teased that with uncle sam
they brought it back at the very end
yeah and
you know
our little details because i did i
didn't notice that dipper's book said
three and i was like i guess the books
are named two and three
yes it's just a quirk or there's gotta
be a one somewhere i don't know yeah
and that was i love that as a as a
little through line and a good
opportunity like i thought it was nice
that they went that way of like he's
convinced dipper has a difference i
don't freaking know what you're talking
about and then it becomes the answer to
the mystery from the from day one from
episode one it's like a nice tie around
you guys are right the show gets much
better
by the way if it becomes like a real
show the more it goes it it grows and
blossoms yeah yeah because these last
few have been a real series and this was
the most i was like
this gets you in the heart in a
different way yeah it gets you really
caught up in the in the fun and the
peril
you know and and the and i don't know
there's something about the way they
draw like you know it's effective sorry
to cut you off on that because i i
didn't realize we were watching the
finale
and as someone who just thought who was
watching another episode i was like this
is really an effective episode yeah
sometimes when you watch something in
the lens of knowing it's a finale you
view it differently you expect yeah a
certain amount of stakes and a certain
amount of like the better this isn't the
television
episode yeah we pulled all the stops out
and got real creative but the way they
they realized this one i was like this
is a really solid uh oh i'm really
invested in like it might not be the
funniest one
um but that's kind of what i mainly
tuned into gravity falls in the first
half of this journey was the funny and
now i
lately i can actually just enjoy the
episode as it's just an episode of
television and the and the laughs can be
pretty unexpected a lot of the time
sometimes it's the obvious jokes i feel
like i'm like you don't really need a
joke here i like this this uh
hispanic made joke i see all the time
and everything that was really
popularized by how family guy did it
yeah i see like so much like this this
joke is so old now like we need to stop
this let's make a new joke old lady oh
the hispanic lady who cleans i get it
yep they love to clean
and they're uh
such a stereotype yeah yeah which part
of me wonders like okay well i guess you
know maybe maybe there is a truth to it
but at the same time it would be nice to
see people put a spin on it instead of
just hey it's the joke again in this
piece of fiction instead of that piece
of fiction i did like that they revealed
that um
their stupidest character is latino i
know they gave him some culture
and uh you know but susie why the
whitey's are
smarter than somebody that's right zeus
lives in a [ __ ] with his grandma
he's not very bright and he ruins most
things but he's loyal
if you're actually like hispanic or
latino you might be like upset by that
i would be happy to have seuss's i'm not
i'm just like yeah fun fact
yeah
he had no idea that he was that he was
did he ever establish that it didn't
feel like it what a veil lifted wow they
really i hope we dive way deeper into
that what does it say about me i hope
that suits in the second season is all
about his heritage wherever that comes
from
you know i think they're the only line
of family in gravity falls that's right
man
when did they come here
how long has they had roots
when did the seuss lay down roots
nice
and the owl trowel is a hoot
cameo voice performance from rick and
morty's justin roiland again
i like how part of his signature is if
there's a weird commercial with nonsense
language in it it's probably him
all right guys that was a good one
commercial
all right guys well gravity falls
we're almost done with this whole show
that's right man
so
leave us alone
never return
to watch our reactions to season two
subscribe
click that bell
and let's do a pic
ricardo martinez we were just talking
about latino folks
and then i saw your name and i'm like
that might be
some type of
spanish
name could be espanol espanol espanol is
the correct pronunciation espana so
ricardo if you have a name like ricardo
i feel sorry for you not because of the
fact that it's
latino i'm saying that i feel sorry for
you because that means that you have a
lot of pressure to uphold with being
sexy
i've never met an ugly
non-charismatic ricardo no it seems like
it comes with the territory that if
you're called ricardo
that you must imbue
everything it means to be a sexy latin
man so the pressure
you must be under all of the time to
have great dance skills to have a great
body
to be charming to have the right kind of
sexy accent
i don't remember you one bit no son of a
beat yeah it's not fair that people like
you exist montalban you ricardo's are
ruining all the fun for everyone out
there ricky how the hell are
when when john is a single white man
how is he supposed to compete with the
notes we get richards and that just
translates to dick that just sounds
stupid and like oh my god he's probably
like some freaking
opportunist oh yeah that's what you
always think when you hear richard
ricardo's you're getting in the way
of my white friends my richards my white
friends
and like coc k blocked when can we get
ricardo gear in the building cross the
two streams white guy hispanic name
what else sexy sonny [ __ ] so hot dude
[Music]